Speaker 1: There's this continued rift that
is taking place within right wing media at
this point in time.
One element of this is that once again, supposedly
Fox News is refusing to air my pillow ads
for Michael and Dell's company, My Pillow.
We've talked about some aspects of this before.
My pillow is a company owned by the right
wing, or Michael Lendell, who's been a guest
on this program that sells pillows and other
elements of sleeping and.
They used to advertise all the time on Fox
News would spend a ton of money advertising
on Fox News and presumably get a pretty good
return for it.
That's why he kept doing it.
And Fox News has now on multiple occasions
supposedly refused to air his ads.
In part, it is believed to be because of the
connection between Michael Andell and false
claims about the 2020 election.
There's a new article in Salon which says
Michael in Dallas begging Fox News to start
airing his ads again, but the network refuses.
Lyndell wants his ads back on Fox, but it
appears the cable behemoth isn't ready to
take him back quite yet.
The BP CEO angrily pulled his company's advertisements
from Fox in July after it ignored the lead
up to a South Dakota cyber symposium and declined
to run an ad for the gathering.
But after nearly two months away, the betting
magnate appears to finally be ready to make
up with the conservative network.
Lyndell laid out.
The situation says he's been trying to increase
to our increasingly watered down versions
of his ads, but that Fox News doesn't like
it.
Let's go to an interview with Mike Lyndell.
This guy really seems off his rocker, but
if it is indeed true that Fox is refusing
to air them, it could signal an interesting
sort of line in the sand, even for Fox News
as far as ads go.
Let's listen.
Speaker 6: Oh, because I don't know what swim
is going to right.
He's you know, he's so far left, you can't
even see him and he's so far left.
He takes a corner and he'll even tell you
that.
But he's very I like him, though, because
he's very you know, he'll read back to me
at least what my quotes were.
So here's the facts.
I you know, everybody before the Cyber Symposium,
I put out an ad on Fox telling people about
free speech, dot com and the cyber symposium.
I pulled that out to every station in the
country.
Fox News was the only one to deny that.
And that includes your CNN, MSNBC and ABC,
CBS.
Remember, I advertised everywhere with my
pillow, and this was an ad that was accepted
for free, directing people to the site to
watch the cyber symposium.
Speaker 1: You guys are following this, right?
Speaker 6: That's all it was.
So when Fox can't when Fox were not allowed,
what did not want to be part of this culture?
What about it with them?
Shame on Fox.
So I canceled all my pillow ads right.
Speaker 1: Now, that's interesting that a
private company saying we don't want your
business is council culture as far as Mike
Pillow is concerned.
Speaker 6: Then we put an ad up two weeks
later, everybody, and after the cyber symposium
and that one said, hey, just go to free speech
and you can see great, great shows and you
can see if you miss the cyber symposium.
Speaker 1: Well, that's not truth in advertising.
There are not great shows on frank speech.
That would be a lie.
Speaker 6: Fox was the only one in the country
that denied that it ran this week.
Its early last week, I put another ad.
I said nothing about the cyber symposium.
I said, go to free speech dot com.
You can see great shows.
We showed some of the shows.
You're songs are all the shows with
Speaker 1: diamonds and silk are now on free
speech.
Can you imagine what is happening to this
country?
Speaker 6: And you can get great products
from my talent and my store.
We did that.
Speaker 1: By the way.
Do you guys hear what sound like whippets
happening in the background?
Speaker 6: Fox said that they didn't like
the content of the ad.
They didn't like us.
Just say, oh, no, the first two had to sit
with about some bullshit.
They didn't like the content of the ads.
That's why they wouldn't take because it said
symposium.
Right then this stirred a fox.
They didn't like the content over it.
There's either a
Speaker 1: woodpecker or someone's huffing
Speaker 6: whippets.
Each brand, they didn't like your show.
They know what they want.
Fox is on my show.
I guess not, but that's.
No, no, no.
It gets worse, everybody.
So they said they said one.
They didn't like the content of the ad, too.
They didn't like the content of the ad three.
They didn't like the content of the platform,
the website, free speech, the stuff that was
on free speech.
Chakram All right.
Speaker 1: What a victim, huh?
Guys, it is just horrible what's going on
with Mike Pillow.
What's interesting about this, the noise in
the background is interesting, I will admit,
but it's very interesting that there is now
this entire wing of the right, the diamond
and Silk, Mike Pillow, et cetera, Newsmax
owned wing.
It's too radical for Fox News.
Like at the end of the day, Fox is right wing,
but Fox wants to make money.
They want to be in rather than out.
And you even now have people who watch Newsmax
saying Fox has become left wing, the mike
pillow types, the January 6th types and others,
and Newsmax is now running an ad.
I'll play it on a live stream.
I don't think I'll talk about it on the podcast,
but I'll play it on an upcoming livestream.
There's Newsmax now has an ad where in the
ad it's audio of Trump saying Fox is so so.
But Newsmax is doing really well at this point
in time.
So a very strange rift happening within right
wing media.
But even Fox News saying some of this stuff
is even too crazy
for us.